we've been tested and i think we've
proven ourselves to be
uh battle tough thank you welcome
it's been a year of quick adjustments
according to three square food bank's
chief operating officer larry scott
during a normal year three square
distributes 4.5 million pounds of food a
month
during the pandemic that number
increased to 5.6 million pounds
each month the demand was extraordinary
for sure with unemployment at an
all-time high in southern nevada due to
the economic fallout of covet 19
food insecurity soared to record levels
with more than 360 000 people needing
assistance
and one in four children now lives in a
food insecure home
add to that a variety of complications
like being able to distribute the food
with social distancing and keeping
people
safe fortunately the warehouse shelves
did not go bare
with help from local and national donors
who rose to the occasion
and helped provide the food that was
needed you want bread cereal
federal programs allowed ccsd to
distribute food at most of the schools
throughout the year
scott says when you take a look back i
think everyone would look at this
and say mission accomplished he credits
her hospitality industry that drives so
much of our economy
while resorts and hotels were forced to
shut their doors they
never turned their back on three squares
mission they continued to send out their
furlough employees to help us they gave
us access to their parking lots
they emptied out their freezers and
their coolers and their pantries and
provided us the food
so you know we are a we are a unique
community by
many many measures but i can say that
this big engine of hospitality that
drives our economy
is a really really generous donor and
something that we should be very proud
of in southern nevada
the doors to three square opened up once
again on may 27th to volunteers
back to business as usual the
opportunities to pack meals and sort
produce
pre-pandemic 3 square had 200 volunteers
a day
right now the number is less than half
that the real heavy demand picks up
again when school starts back
up in less than two months we have
volunteers that donate money
we have volunteers that donate time some
who donate food
during the pandemic some sown masks
people volunteer in so many different
ways some are driving
and delivering food to seniors who are
homebound
so we just have a variety of different
ways
that people can help and at
threesquare.org it's a perfect map to
lead you
to where you can find your little niche
to be able to help in this effort